[موسيقى]
عليك يا مريم
سيده لبنانيه تبلغ من العمر 94 عاما
اولادها الخمسه يعانون من اوضاع المعيشيه
مترديه ولا يستطيعون اعانتها نخلي تتمنى
ان يكون وضعها مجرده كابوسه سينتهي
قرشين فقد عمله ولا يستطيع العثور على
مصدر رزق ثابت بينما حالته الصحيه
لانه عندي كتير
حتى فحوصاتي ما بعمله يعني لو ما براد
الحي بيعطينا اكل والجمعيات بساعدونا
عربي
هشاشه في المجتمع لكنها لا تستطيع مساعده
الجميعا
كلكم
موجود عنا موجود بالسوق على السريع من
امنوا اذا في فحوصات معين نقدر نحنا نفوت
فيها اكيد نفوت فيها كمان بنوزع مواد
غذائيه همم لشريحه كثير كبيره من المجتمع
مش بس تموت غزيئيه من وجع وقت الثياب في
اولاد بدون ثياب وهلا فتره اعياد امانه
عندك ناس عن جد ما لنا قادر اجيب ربطه خبز
عم نقدر يعني من لحمه الحياني 6000 عائله
اللبنانيين
طبعا اليوم في عده اسباب من البطاله لانه
وقت اللي بنحكي عن البطاله يعني انسان فقد
دخله من دون اي ضمانه فهو ارتفاع بالفقر
في عندنا التضخم يعني نحنا اليوم التضخم
تقريبا تجاوز 850% في حين انه الليره
اللبنانيه فقدت قيمتها
لبنان يعيش
ون لما تفاقمت الازمه ارتفعت نسبه الفقر
بين اللبنانيين